foreign
comic books you've posted I want to say
photographs of 350 or so rejection
letters yep when did you first start
sending those out and did you get any
particularly helpful feedback that
allowed you to modify things so that you
were able to get that first job
so let's go through it real quick
did I get
over 300 rejections yes is that
tenacious is that determination or is
that delusion what point do you say I'm
going to be an opera singer and people
keep giving you no's and you go man look
at how determined is at what point do
you say maybe I just can't sing opera
right right so there's a fine line
people give me way too much credit for
those 300 I think a normal sane person
with sort of less enthusiasm we'll leave
it at that word than me would have
probably at 200 rejections found another
option to make money but the reason I
was able to assimilate that many
rejections was because I was going to
college so I was sending off samples
almost continuously
while I was in in school so it's like I
didn't have a job I was going to school
so I didn't care I had four years to
basically try and get a job and then it
probably at the end of those four years
I was going to look at that pile and say
maybe I need to find something else my
degree is I thought is in graphic
designing and I thought I was going to
be the guy who's going to do Michelin
tire ads right I go that's okay it's an
admirable job but you know it's a
graphic designer that was sort of where
I thought the reality of it was going to
be
so but three weeks before I graduate I
get my first job and how did I get it by
sending literally 700 samples over the
course of those four years and just on
one level I think I just wore them out
because I sent it to every editor at
every company and so they they used to
have let's say at Marvel because my
first job was at Marvel they have like
one submission editor no no no no no no
the people who give you the work are the
editors and they have 16 editors so I
would send it to all 16 editors
ultimately I went around this submission
guy I just want what you're not you're
not you got to give it to the editors
anyways might as well send it directly
to the editors so I would keep sending
it to the editors over and over and over
to every company every editor and I
think Tim and hindsight I think that
they probably had a board meeting or
whatever one of those Monday morning
meetings and they just said something
like and I'm making this up but said
over the love of God that Todd kid that
that that punk that keeps sending us we
keep getting like a box of mail from
this guy every two weeks with somebody
in this room give him a couple Pages
just so we don't have to open up his
mail every two weeks I think I just I
think I just wore him out and and I got
the job literally three weeks before I
graduated so I never even had to use my
degree now what informed me in those it
was all constructive criticism let me
tell you because people say oh Todd you
got the last lap no no
everything they put in those letters was
constructive criticism because the
people who just thought that I was you
know not very good through my my
portfolio my samples in the garbage so
everybody who took the time to write
back actually gave a little bit of sort
of insight and so what I would do that
didn't know it was actually going to
keep me fueled is that I would take that
insight and then redo another batch and
send it to everybody again so I you know
where I was making 20 mistakes
eventually got down to 18 and then 16
and then 15 and I think probably when I
was at six mistakes I think they finally
said hey he's getting better he's not
perfect but and he seems to be
enthusiastic so somebody give them give
them a chance see what he can do